Although Mad Max: Fury Road got rave reviews,
Rosie Huntington-Whiteley didn't use her part
as a springboard to advance her acting career.
In fact, you might not have seen
Rosie in a hot minute. Here's why.
Mad Max: Fury Road was universally praised,
and Rosie Huntington-Whiteley's performance
was well received. However, her big screen
debut in Transformers: Dark of the Moon
was panned by critics. In the third installment
of the Transformers franchise, Huntington-Whiteley
replaced Megan Fox as Shia LaBeouf's love
interest. The reviews were so scathing it's
no wonder she didn't appear in another film for
four years. A review from Total Film remarked,
"[Rosie Huntington-Whiteley was] sucking the
life out of every scene she appeared in."
Every entertainer knows that they can't please
everyone, and the Transformers franchise was
never a hit with critics no matter who
was part of the human cast. However,
Huntington-Whiteley said she did her best
to pay attention and learn from the role.
Shortly after the release of Mad Max:
Fury Road, Rosie Huntington-Whiteley
and her boyfriend Jason Statham went public with
the exciting news that they'd gotten engaged.
Huntington-Whiteley showed off her sparkly
new rock at the Golden Globes in January 2016.
The couple has been together since 2010, and
Huntington-Whiteley says that Statham has been
much more understanding of her ambitious career
goals than some of her previous boyfriends.
"Are you threatened by him?"
Huntington-Whiteley and Statham are both extremely
passionate about their work, and this connection
only makes their relationship stronger. As
the model and actress told Elle Australia,
"When you're a career-driven person, it works
best when your partner is equally as excited
for you and supportive. And that's what Jason
is. He's my biggest cheerleader and I'm his."
Although they're both quite busy
with their respective careers,
they like to have plenty of family time outside
of the spotlight, and Huntington-Whiteley makes
it a point to keep their relationship fairly
private. They both make an effort to make the
most of their time off together, which means not
taking on every project that comes their way.
Rosie Huntington-Whiteley wears many
professional hats, and by putting
acting on the back burner, she was able
to focus on some of her other passions,
like fashion design. She had already worked on a
lingerie line for British brand Marks and Spencer,
which turned out to be a massive success, so
it's easy to see why the label Paige chose
to partner with her for a collaborative
collection. This was a huge undertaking,
but Huntington-Whiteley was happy to
take on the challenge. As she told Elle,
"I've always wanted to be a designer, ever since I
can remember. [...] It's brilliant to come to work
and bring something else to the table beside my
modeling; it's great when people want to listen
to you and want you to be a part of something
bigger than just being the face of a brand."
The first collection was
launched in February 2017,
and a second was launched in the fall of
2017. It's clear that this is an area where
Huntington-Whiteley really excels and feels
comfortable expressing herself creatively.
With all the time she's spent acting, modeling,
and working on her other business ventures,
it's hard to imagine how Rosie Huntington-Whiteley
could possibly fit anything more into her busy
life. Eventually, juggling all of these
commitments was bound to become too much,
and as a result, certain projects
inevitably fell by the wayside.
Shortly before being cast in Mad Max: Fury
Road, Huntington-Whiteley had been pushing
for the presenter spot on the long-running
reality TV series Project Runway All Stars.
After getting confirmation that she'd
landed the job, she abruptly backpedaled.
Unfortunately for the show, this all went down
mere weeks before filming was slated to begin.
When she was offered the part in Mad Max: Fury
Road, she decided that her role in the film was
more important, which unexpectedly left the
cast and crew of Project Runway All Stars
in search of a different host. It isn't uncommon
for scheduling conflicts to happen in Hollywood,
but it still probably didn't do her any favors
with the people behind the scenes at Project
Runway All Stars, and she may have realized that
choosing Hollywood over the fashion industry might
not be such a smart career move. Trying to do it
all would just mean spreading herself too thin.
In June 2017, Rosie Huntington-Whiteley and Jason
Statham welcomed their son, Jack. Like pretty much
any doting mom, Huntington-Whiteley never misses
a chance to gush about how much she loves him.
Although she did take several months off to stay
home with Jack and adjust to being a new mom,
she says that since she came back to work,
she and Statham now try to split their
parenting responsibilities equally.
With Statham's time on film sets,
it would be difficult for both of
them to balance time with Jack if
Huntington-Whiteley was acting too.
Now, their schedule works out perfectly.
Statham is in charge of Jack in the morning,
while Huntington-Whiteley takes care of
the nighttime routine and puts him to bed.
"He is very happy to get up at 5 a.m. in
the morning and like do daddy duties."
The couple is adamant that their
son should be raised with plenty
of involvement from both parents.
As the model told Harper's Bazaar,
"I think it's so much about raising boys
and girls the same. [...] That's how I
was brought up, it's how the
people I love were brought up,
and they are the values I hope
to instill in my loved ones."
Ask any parent how their life has
changed after they've had a kid,
and many will probably tell you that they're not
too keen on staying late at the office anymore,
as they would rather get home early and have
plenty of time with their family instead.
As it turns out, even celebrities struggle to
strike that balance. Rosie Huntington-Whiteley
has been very forthcoming about the
fact that she now considers her son
Jack's needs before she agrees to take any
potential new job. She told Harper's Bazaar,
"The first thing in your mind
before accepting a job is,
what's right for my family? [...] The
new thing is getting used to having a
lot of responsibilities in my personal life and
career. [...] For every woman, it's a juggle."
"We've been so like focused on our work
for so long, and then Jack came along."
In the early days of her career, Rosie
Huntington-Whiteley couldn't afford to be
picky with her projects, and just like any new
model, she had to be open-minded about the jobs
that came her way. But now, she's certainly not
scrounging for work. As one of the most in-demand
models in the industry, she can be as choosy
as she wants to be, and she calls the shots.
It seems that 30 was the magic turning
point for Huntington-Whiteley. After
spending nearly 15 years in the industry, she
felt like she had finally gained a solid grasp
on the kinds of jobs that she did or didn't
want to take on. As she told Harper's Bazaar UK,
"I've settled into my life [...] I
know myself and what makes me happy."
Rosie Huntington-Whiteley started
her lifestyle brand, Rose Inc.,
while taking her hiatus from modeling to stay home
with son Jack. Huntington-Whiteley says that while
acting or modeling, other people are typically
in control of the decisions and final product,
but she wanted to pursue a project
where she would have the final say.
After years of taking direction from
others, she was ready to make a statement
and kick off a whole new phase in
her career. She told Net-a-Porter,
"I just never felt comfortable sitting
back and waiting for other people to make
decisions for me. [...] I've always wanted
to be in control of where my life is going."
Right now, the site features interviews
with models and beauty industry moguls,
updates on innovative new
products, and makeup tutorials.
It's clear that this is Huntington-Whiteley's
passion, and it's a space where she gets
to share all of her interests and
beauty know-how with her friends.
As for why she didn't try to establish herself
as an actress after the success of Mad Max:
Fury Road, Rosie Huntington-Whiteley is
a model first and foremost. As of 2018,
Huntington-Whiteley was ranked sixth on the Forbes
official rankings of the highest earning models in
the world. And those rankings were released while
she was on her maternity break. At this point,
she has the freedom to fully lean into the talents
that have taken her to the top of the ladder,
and she knows that she has always had a certain
natural gift for modeling and fashion design.
There's a time for trying new things, and
there's a time for embracing your innate
talents and just running with them, and that seems
to be where Huntington-Whiteley is at right now.
"It's really about, you know,
enhancing the things that you love about
yourself and playing on those things."
At the beginning of her modeling
career, Rosie Huntington-Whiteley
said she was simply expected to sit in
front of the camera and look pretty,
and she was frustrated with the expectation that
models should stay silent. She says that over
the past few years, she's gotten sick of that
feeling, and if she can't give her input and
take part in the artistic process, she's just not
interested. Huntington-Whiteley told Net-a-Porter,
"If shoots aren't a collaborative
process then I'm not really interested,
because I don't want to feel like I did
for the first ten years of my career,
which is that I was just having stuff done to me."
And as a newcomer to Hollywood,
Huntington-Whiteley probably didn't
have much sway when it came to how she played
her roles. Perhaps she missed feeling confident
and having a certain level of authority while
having a director in charge of her every move.
Rosie Huntington-Whiteley's dream
was always to become a model,
and she made that dream come true at
a young age. But becoming an actress
was never one of her goals. Those
roles happened to fall into her lap,
and while she was grateful for the chance to be
part of two franchises that she was a fan of,
acting wasn't part of her long-term career plan.
Huntington-Whiteley told The Daily Telegraph,
"They were just incredible opportunities that I've
grasped [...] I think you'll agree when you get
to be in a film like Mad Max or Transformers,
you'd be crazy to say no and turn that down."
Huntington-Whiteley has always seen
herself as a model before anything else.
She has the incredible career
that she has always envisioned,
and while she's glad that she gave
acting a shot, it just wasn't for her.
After spending years in Hollywood, Rosie
Huntington-Whiteley and her family decided
to pack up and move to London in the U.K.
On Instagram, Huntington-Whiteley frequently
shares photos from her spacious new home, and she
occasionally posts shots from around the city.
Since Huntington-Whiteley was born and raised
in England, it's safe to say that she wanted
to be closer to her family, and perhaps she was
just feeling a little homesick after living so
far from her loved ones. While there are plenty of
opportunities for actors in London, it's unlikely
that Huntington-Whiteley would want to relocate
there if she intended to return to acting.
Of course, actors don't necessarily need to be
based in Los Angeles in order to land roles,
but it certainly does help. Maybe she'll decide
to come back to California one day, but for now,
it looks like Huntington-Whiteley and her family
will be staying on the other side of the pond.
Huntington-Whiteley wanted to go
beyond running her own beauty site.
She's also passionate about
high-quality cosmetics,
and she's had the opportunity to collaborate with
several top beauty brands to create new products.
In 2020, Huntington-Whiteley became the
first celebrity ambassador for Hourglass
Cosmetics, and she launched a new line of
concealers and lipsticks with the brand.
In January 2021, Huntington-Whiteley worked
with another beauty brand, La Bouche Rouge
to release two new shades of lipstick. She
announced that a portion of the proceeds
from this particular collection would go to the
non-profit organization Eau Vive Internationale,
which provides communities with clean
drinking water. Huntington-Whiteley has
spoken of her admiration for the beauty brand
on numerous occasions, and told The Zoe Report,
"I first came across La Bouche Rouge soon
after it launched in 2017 and instantly
fell in love with the sustainability
mission, the clean formulations,
and how the lipstick cases felt like a keepsake."
While Huntington-Whiteley
may not be acting right now,
she's certainly busy enough with other projects.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.